[Music]
let's talk about Cesar Chavez you had a
screening of this film at the White
House last week and you you brought your
mom oh yeah and and your mom was hoping
to meet the president yeah when she
realized that she wasn't meeting him I
she was like this law audible like like
when I came back in so you got you got
to hang with the president but she did
not yeah apparently we all got shuffled
at like we weren't really sure we all
walked in then we got shuffled into
another room and it's just the cast and
crew who got to take you know haven't
meeting with him like really quickly and
a lot of sweat that didn't go in like my
americas husband didn't go in like it
was just us and then we came back out
and he introduced the film and when he
was talking about it Pablo Cruz was one
of the producers said that he would give
him a copy of the movie
mm-hmm because he wasn't gonna be able
to watch it with us so being president
yeah exactly and he was like oh this
will be so great cuz Michelle and the
girls just went off to China I'll be
able to watch it this weekend he goes
I'll get the CD and play it and my mom
was like DVD it and he was like oh you
know yes she was like DVD I'm
technologically challenged and I was
like see mom your mom that's I don't
think so DVD was such a mom moment
though like you're doing press get it
right that's so cool okay well we have a
clip here from Cesar Chavez clearly a
very important figure a very important
film what can you tell us about this
clip this is when you know they're
trying to take it to the next gear you
know where they're really gonna expand
the boycott and take it all the way
through to get even more people to be a
part of the movement not just the
farmworkers and this is where the
success really comes in is when everyone
starts to take this idea of people who
pick our food being able to feed their
own families and everyone being a part
of that story okay let's take a look at
this clip from Cesar Chavez people are
starting to lose hope and I don't blame
them they know the growers have broken
the strike with the illegal workers and
the sweetheart deal with the Teamsters
we can't ask them to keep going when
they see people working in the fields we
have to take the next step
until week we have no laws to protect us
here with the boycott there are no laws
to stop us this is the moments you say
this is what we came here to do still
the same issues so a lot of the same
issues I hope people watch this is sort
of like activism 101 you really see what
it took to to have farmworkers organized
in small town of Delano and have it
build across California across America
go into and through the White House and
out into Europe was one of the largest
nonviolent movements we've ever seen and
so I hope that people build on it today
all right we'll check out this film